here's the thought people that are
struggling financially will be better
off if they become homeowners that's the
thought based on that thought the US
government in conjunction with the
mortgage companies and the mortgage
industry put in place a whole series of
loans like the one we were just
discussing and many many others that
made you able to buy a home with no
money and in many cases are not even
qualifying for the loan the ninja loans
if you remember those by qualifying
there's a no qualifying no assets no job
no income and you can qualify for a home
because of this monkey thought that if
you're struggling financially you'll be
better off if you are a homeowner
because home ownership leads 12 now the
problem with the thought is it's wrong
now it's not a matter of perception some
things are right some things are wrong
some things are good some things are
evil some things are black some things
are white that's you know we've got this
thing let's just a matter it's just your
viewpoint not other viewpoints some
things are stupid this was stupid and we
have illustrated in the past five to
seven years how stupid it is in this
culture because we helped a whole bunch
of broke people buy homes and then the
stupid government and the stupid
mortgage industry started treating these
nothing down no job no assets no income
no credit record loans as if they were
prime loans packaged them together and
sold them on Wall Street as a security
first in hedge funds and then they
normalized it there and it finally
became normalized to where that then
everybody's buying these bonds as if
they were real mortgages and they were
crap because they were broke people that
paid full freaking price for a house
with nothing down there's no equity
there's no margin in these deals well
the real estate world turned upside down
and guess what all these broke people
gave their houses back and crashed the
whole free
King economy because this wonky thought
that everybody buys a house everybody's
better off is wrong it's wrong now
should everyone aspire to homeownership
yes I think so
I think homeownership is excellent and
so you aspire to getting yourself out of
the position of broke if you look under
the broke column and you see your face
get to work get yourself out of the
broke column move over to the not broke
column put a good down payment on a
house with an emergency fund in place
and no other debt when you own a home
and you're financially stable a home is
a blessing financially when you own a
home when you're broke it's a curse
financially homeownership buy broke
people makes them broker that's why they
call them mortgage brokers this is the
never MZ show
you